now a building has collapsed and the
City of chandelierfa in Southeastern
turkey the structure was damaged during
last month's earthquakes and had
previously been evacuated our
correspondent Teresa Beau reports now
from the ground today in shanyard
we're here in the center of the city of
Chandler this is Southern Eastern Turkey
where a six-story building has collapsed
right here in the center of the city it
had been previously damaged during the
earthquakes that happened in February
and now it collapsed it's not clear yet
why this building had been cleared it
had been cordoned mostly because it was
one of the building that was going to be
demolished in the city around 2500
buildings were expecting to be
demolished after the earthquake and this
one simply collapsed the government has
sent in search and rescue teams we do
know that one person was injured but
it's not clear yet whether people have
been trapped underneath the rubble
supposedly this area had been already
been evacuated but still the government
wants to make sure and that's why search
and rescue teams are here right now
there's hundreds of thousands of
buildings that either collapsed or were
severely damaged during the earthquakes
and that that's why the government is
moving forward trying to demolish them
trying to clear the rubble from the
center of the city they have been
warning people to stay away from
buildings such as this one because
there's been lots of cases where people
go inside to pick up some of their
belongings then there is an Aftershock
or another earthquake the buildings
collapse and people have been trapped
inside and many have lost their lives so
there's lots of tension on the ground
lots of Anguish because people here in a
way remind them of what happened of the
earthquakes that happened one month ago